if you watch typescript versus
JavaScript
is a like a split in the community over
types right that seems to be stabilizing
now it's not necessarily a split there
are certainly plenty of people who don't
use typescript but
just use the original JavaScript
notation just like there are many people
in the python world who don't use type
annotations and don't use static type
Checkers no I know but there is a bit of
a split between typescript and
JavaScript old school JavaScript EES
whatever well in the JavaScript world
transpilers are sort of the standard way
of working anyway which is why
typescript being a transpiler itself is
not a big deal and transpose for people
who don't know it's what's exactly the
thing you said with my pies it's the
code I guess you call it pre-processing
code that translates from one language
to the other and that's part of the
culture part of the workflow of the
JavaScript community so that's right at
the same time
an interesting development in the
JavaScript slash typescript world at the
moment is that
there is a proposal under consideration
it's only a stage one proposal
that proposes to add a feature to
JavaScript where just like python it
will ignore certain syntax
when uh running the JavaScript code
and what it ignores is more or less a
superset of uh The typescript annotation
syntax
interesting so that would mean that
eventually if you wanted to you could
take typescript
uh and you could shove it directly into
a JavaScript interpreter without
translation
the interesting thing in the JavaScript
world at least the web browser world the
web browsers have changed how they
deploy and uh they they sort of update
their JavaScript engines
much more quickly than they used to in
the the early days and so there's much
less of a need for
transplation in JavaScript itself
because most browsers just support the
most recent version of ecmascript just
in a tangent of attention do you see if
you will recommend somebody use a thing
would you recommend typescript or
JavaScript
I would recommend uh typescript just
because of the strictness of the typing
it's an enormously helpful extra tool
that helps you sort of
keep your head straight about what your
code is actually doing
I mean it's it's it it helps with
editing your code it helps with ensuring
that your code
is not too incorrect
and it's actually
quite compatible with JavaScript never
mind this syntactic sort of hack that is
still years in the future
but any library that is written in pure
JavaScript can still be used from
typescript programs and also the other
way around you can write a library in
typescript and then export it in a form
that is totally consumable by JavaScript
that sort of compatibility is is sort of
the key to this to the success of
typescript
yeah just to look at it as almost like a
biological system that's evolving it's
fascinating to see JavaScript evolve the
way it does well maybe we should
consider that biological systems are
just the Engineering Systems too right
yes but very Advanced with more history
but it's almost like the most visceral
in the JavaScript world because there's
just so much code written in JavaScript
that for its history was messy if you
talk about bugs per line of code I just
feel like JavaScript
eats the cake or whatever the
terminology is it beats python by a lot
in terms of number of bugs meaning like
way more bugs in JavaScript and then and
then the obviously the browsers the
developing it's just there's so much
active development it feels a lot more
like Evolution where a bunch of stuff is
born and dies and there's
experimentation and debates versus
python is more
um all that stuff is happening but
there's just a longer history of stable
working giant software systems written
in python versus JavaScript is just a
giant beautiful I would say mess of code
it's very different culture and
to some extent differences in culture
are random but to some extent they the
differences have to do with the
environment yeah uh and the fact that
JavaScript is primarily
the language for uh developing web
applications especially the client side
and the fact that it's basically the
only language for developing web
applications
makes that Community sort of just have a
different nature than the community of
other languages
plus the graphical component
um and the fact that they're deploying
it on all kinds of uh shapes of screens
and devices and all that kind of stuff
it just creates a beautiful chaos